okay hi everyone we have a slightly
different kind of live stream today we
are looking at a different group that
hasn't been doing live stream meetings
uh this is part of our cor software
engineering effort and we are looking at
error handling in wolam language um new
approach to
that so where do we want to start here
so I thought we could start with um I
mean it's worth saying all of this
functionality is highly experimental um
so we expect a lot of the parts of the
design to change I thought what we could
look at today as as a follow-up to a
live stream from last week is naming for
many of these functions um we think we
have a good understanding yeah of the
basic functionality but the names could
definitely be improved so where's the
guide page where I can actually see
these functions it's right here yeah
yeah okay so let's start off
um so I'm trying to remember this rays
and handle are both instant action
functions right they break the control
flow correct
correct by the way does anybody know
what happened to the fail safe
function my understanding is that
Christopher was working on that um okay
all right fine uh but but its name has
not changed it's it's that's its name
right corre current name I don't I don't
know if that is believed to be the final
name I like that name but I the reason
I'm bringing that up is because I think
that's a naming
convention that I mean what fail safe
does
is it evaluates exper
and what happens if if that what is the
deal here if that
fails remind me how this
works somebody remind me how this works
yeah I have to go and yeah Christopher's
not here to Christopher's the this is
this was actually you know it's always
on the potential agenda for these ECE
meetings but Christopher's not here so
okay well fine we'll have to do it the
time when Christopher is here
but but I just it's roughly this right
it's it's trying to evaluate something
and if it fails it's going to the
failure case and cleaning itself up as I
recall yeah here I'm gonna Christ
Christopher sorry Stephen I'm sending
you an email right now with
Christopher's examples notebook okay um
let me just uh oh something
is some reason I can't all right give me
just a
sec okay
momentarily all right copy
that do the
email all right I just sent that to you
and
DC okay all right I just I just want to
understand this but
then wait what are things like a prize
is that a real thing or is that
something
um that's I mean it's not a it's a
placeholder name for
the concept of kind of the rep like a
structured replacement for messages or
alternative to messages um I see so a
prize was a I mean we had some other
things like advise emit note um inform
things along those lines okay okay okay
so oh I see what this is doing yeah this
is a good fun piece of
functionality right okay so I understand
this functionality I
think okay this is the key example I
think it's an interesting
function like just don't do other if you
don't see the food if if the thing
you're being fed is poisonous don't eat
it would be one
summary okay let's let's start taking a
look at these things
so where where do we want to start here
what what is the um so in that same
email I sent you I also sent the kind of
the basic examples notebook um from our
last
meeting
um so I think the place that we ended up
in that meeting was a discussion of this
set fall through error function um which
even for its current behavior is is not
a great name okay I think it's about
halfway
down all right
so thing I don't like about Ray as a
name is that you know it breaks the
control flow and Rays just seems like oh
you're putting up a flag you know oh you
know hello I'm you know whatever throw
for example indicates clearly something
is happening now here and
now yeah I I'm partial to the name um
and actually this exists in that you'll
notice if in that uh output from the
question mark the information command
you did there's the symbol fail is
defined and it's currently just an alias
for rays um I guess it was fail it's
actually fail to because fail is a
system symbol already though it's used
in an extremely esoteric way
um how is it used my understanding is
it's it's a magic Sentinel value that's
part of the rule condition
implementation in C code in the kernel
oh yeah yeah right it's from version
point8 it's part of the thing that never
got
finished yeah was part of part of the
mechanism for backing out of a
rule yeah um so it's I mean it's never
been documented in its form and it's
okay I don't think I don't think we have
to preserve of that yeah I don't think
it will be in it's not in code it's not
in a notebook anywhere it's just an
internal thing yeah well I mean given
that failure is being what what's
being
um I don't know what's the argument to
it if if it's if it's fail what is its
argument well if its arguments were the
same as Rays they would be essentially
the same as the arguments structure for
failure a tag an association of you know
properties and some kind of error
message
optionally
yeah I mean really the only required
argument is the tag and all the other
arguments kind of have default values of
no message no extra
properties do you need the
tag can we have a generic tag like well
or that's the disaster of throw that it
has a generic
tag uh I'm sorry when I say tag I'm not
talking about the tag that's used for
throwing and catching I'm talking about
the tag of the failure object
um our our design for rays is that it
has it's it's not a user controllable
tag it's a a fixed value every
invocation of Ray has the same
tag I'm totally confused what do this
two error about that so that that's the
tag I'm referring to the error tag and
it's it's this is an existing thing you
were talking about the throw tag is
fixed yes I know yes the throw tag is
I'm sorry okay yeah throw tag is fixed
this tag is variable uh it's the same
notion of you know it's it's kind of a a
machine readable string or symbol that
is meant to impart some semantic
information about the failure that was
thrown what what type of failure it is
um currently we don't have a lot of
infrastructure for handling these things
based on these tags so the tags are in
some sense arbitrary um but building
that infrastructure is something we'd
like to see
happen also in a way tags are the whole
uh reason why how this is different from
catch and throw because tags could be
organized in hierarchies and basically
if you are building your own module you
can define a root tag for that module
and all the sub errors of that module
could be caught within a single handle
statement what that
tag okay
well I don't understand how is the tag
hierarchical by your choice or yeah
correct you can when you define your
error type you can Define what the
parents of that error type are which
tags are parent tags for that okay so
it's not okay if you want to see an
example of that copy that create error
type of Foo error yeah um then we put
this all in the right notebook I guess
and go ahead and evaluate that and then
duplicate
it um new input same idea but change Fu
error to Bar error and then put Fu error
as an element of that
list and then uh do rays of bar
error um and I think you'll need to put
it in just just put in some you know an
error occurred kind of string is the
second
argument yeah
okay and go ahead and evaluate that
evaluate that
so you can see what came out as a
failure that has two tags we we're doing
a tag expansion is what we call it um to
get the fully elaborated set of tags
that are annotate this
failure
okay
um okay but but okay let's just
understand all right
so raise and handle of are the main
functions raise is breaking the control
flow and with better tagging than
throw is going to the nearest enclosing
handle or the nearest catching enclosing
handle is that correct yes yeah the
nearest handle that has a pattern that
matches the throne failure and the tags
should match so if your handle basically
catches different tags it may still
passs this race through or you know up
until the that has that tag
called have you guys been actually
trying to write code with this
mechanisms
yeah okay all right
so the the primary functions
here what the heck is this create
failure that is added mostly as a like a
as a worker function for rays so Rays
you'll notice it has this argument
structure where it can take a string as
an argument and then a sequence of
format parameters after it create
failure is is just how that failure gets
created that raise then throws so if you
want to create a
failure I mean create in our world is is
creating something which is a a you know
Global thing yeah it is the wrong name
so what is it again uh well go ahead and
just where you have Rays Below in in5
just change that to create failure
it's it's just constructing the failure
that raise
throws
okay what really is this this is a
tagged
failure is that
right or isand failure I mean what is it
it's taking this which would otherwise
in its natural form be just failure of B
era well no it's
it's okay it's entirely po sorry yeah
well it's entirely I mean create failure
does two things that we think are useful
it does the tag expansion and it has
this more convenient Syntax for setting
the message of the failure the second
one certainly I think there's an
argument that that might eventually just
be part of what failure does if you have
a multi-argument failure where the
second argument is not an association
yeah I think so canot to that and also
also Conor what I think we missed the
mentioning here is that create failure
creates those failure objects that are
specialized for this error handling
mechanism so while we still use failure
objects rather than special error
objects or something like that they will
have some special fields that only are
that belong to this error handling
mechanism the new one that we're
suggesting and so create failure will
take care of properly creating these
failure objects with this additional
Fields what additional Fields I don't
see any additional field one thing we've
talked about is stack traces so having
some flag you can set to insert a stack
Trace at the original origin point of a
failure or caused by field which will
basically contain some internal failure
that is causing this one which will
appear in some cases
well yeah I mean cause by is certainly
field but I don't I mean un SL I don't
think it would be create failure that
ads caused by in of itself where where
are we storing this please auy where are
we storing
this I don't know that we I don't think
that we've have existing notes on the
error handling working group in your
hierarchy okay all right because most of
our previous discussions have can we
please remember from project management
point of view that we kind of need to
know the answer to that every time we do
one of these design meetings
MH okay go
ahead um so you're saying this might be
something where um where this has to
pull in current you know this is pulling
in current
state from you know it's a version of
failure version of failure that autop
populates current
state is that
correct yeah roughly I mean autop
current state it it also it does again
it does the tag expansion and it has
that more convenience Syntax for error
message the thing that's really real
here is that it's pulling in a stack
Trace it's doing caused buys it's doing
all those kinds of things which depend
on the current place where it is in the
code yeah right it's a a sort of code
execution context dependent thing yeah
right that's it that's its main reasons
to exist I mean saying oh well it's just
modifying some syntax here and there is
really not a very convincing reason to
exist and probably should be handled
elsewhere there is one more reason
stepen and that is that we eventually
want to unify confirm and close and uh
the ex exception mechanisms at least so
that uh they could still operate on the
same failure objects or similarly typed
failer objects so in that sense having
the create failure or whatever name we
choose for this as a separate function
might allow us to also propagate
similarly formed failures through
confirms and close if we if we decide so
so if we see it I understand I mean yes
it's a failure object that's what we
want we want this thing whatever this
thing is it returns a failure object
that then does what it does and this is
a way of building a failure object that
contains current state information that
would not otherwise be if you just
constructed a failure object by typing
it in you would not put that in there
but you could put it in there but you
would not typically put it in there
right yeah
sure and I mean it it's none of these
names are good but it is essentially a
code it is a it
represents
a you know failure state or something
none of these are good names but it it
represents the main thing we're getting
at here is that this is capturing the
current
state I mean capture failure construct
failure because I think it's it's it's
what you want to emphasize it's like
yeah it is it is what's happening right
now this is not a failure that was
created a while ago it's there's
something special that's happening based
on this place
um
I'm not sure I'm not sure but but I
think we've got the general sense of
this here let's keep going okay yeah um
all right the next big function is
raise yeah correct I let's just take it
take a little look
here
um I mean I don't know why we're not do
we think that arrays is always an error
I mean it's throwing a failure object so
if you're kind of using it as an El Cheo
control flow you know
modifier you know you're going through
the the the the the marsh of failure so
to speak do that makes sense yeah so I
don't think you know having the word
error in the name doesn't seem obviously
wrong yeah I don't definitely don't
disagree I mean I I I personally like
the name fail because it's I mean it's
almost couldn't be any more obvious it's
it's the verb form of the noun that it's
creating like it's a failure but but
it's doing more than that I mean I think
it's it's fail doesn't seem quite right
because it's it's like well you're
you're saying I have a piece of code and
saying if x is greater than zero fail
yeah it's not terrible what are some
other sort of code fragments that it
could appear
in I mean it's going to be something
conditional like that
um well or is it going to be what about
a confirm like thing I mean confirm has
various ways that
it you know in other words if it
says I mean let's just understand this
thing let's say you say confirm
quiet remind me what confirm is going to
do here so confirm quiet if it isn't
quiet it throws a failure to the
enclosing en close correct yeah okay
so what's the difference between it
doing that and AR raise and
handle you get what I'm saying yeah non
locality what do you mean by nonlocality
I mean that the most the dominant way to
use confirm and close is without tanks
when they're lexical while what raay and
handle do is nonlocal in the sense that
the raised failer will propagate up
until it finds on up the stack okay the
first handle that catches it so why
isn't confirm with a tag the same as
Rays it's almost the same but the
problem is now we Face the problem of
identity of an error what this failure
that we are currently propagating does
is that it embeds its own identity that
it can be caught by handle in a
self-contained way while when you do a
confirm and enclose with the tag you
essentially face almost the same issue
as the catch and throw with the tag that
tags exist separately from the actual
thing that you're propagating and they
have to be externally added to the
picture okay let's walk through this
again
okay what would ha I I still want to
understand this sounds crazy to me I
mean it seems to me that we should make
somehow confirm with a tag B raise and
handle walk me through how we would do
that okay so confirm without a tag has
all this lexical stuff which is very
nice locally right but now confirm with
a tag looks like
what well so if you want to I mean if
you want to look at the open example of
confirm what I actually did like before
this effort really got underway what
I've done a lot of projects is I use
confirm to initiate my failures but it's
it's kind of verbose because what you
have to do is I essentially would do you
know confirm at a failure
object because that was the easiest way
to kind of initiate a failure using
confirm okay well then let's see whether
we can capture that here I mean if if
we've already got the confirm and close
mechanism which is a pretty nice
mechanism and you know teaching people
75 other different ways to say the same
thing throw raise handle you know
confirm and close you know it doesn't
seem right but the problem that you're
saying is that there's an elcho version
of confirm enclos which is the local
lexical thing and then there's the
non-local version which you say has to
be has to enclose a bunch of state and
right now the Syntax for doing that is
messy yeah let me see if
um so how do we make it less messy what
does it have to yeah can you give me
some code that will do this yeah
so well I'm sorry I'm trying to find an
example of what you know it looks like
to translate a you know what I was doing
previously to this
um this is going to be a little messy
but
um
okay side
okay so this is not exactly right but
I'm going to put this example in the
zoom chat
um there we go pasting it
now um this is an error from the packet
tools
project now it's for various reasons
it's using failure message which is a
different utility I wrote but for the
moment let's let's pretend that this is
a failure object so this is inside of
actually I guess you probably want the
context for this as well
um here I'll give you actually a better
example kind of what this looks like in
in code where you might initiate this
all right I just put another example in
the zoom chat perhaps
easier
um
so formatting is a bit odd but but
what's Happening Here is I'm testing
some condition you know I need to make
sure that the thing that the user has
passed is a is a list valid list um and
if it's not I'm I'm initiating an error
condition um so the function this this
snippet is from is wrapped in in close
and this is where I'm I'm initiating a
new error so I think our question design
question is here is could we simplify
what's written there into a syntax that
works with confirm um but has the same
outcome
um and I'm sure the answer is
yes I mean by exactly
doing I mean I'm confused because I
thought confirm
usually
just had an expression in it and that it
only does that if the expression I see
what you're doing here is you're
pre-wiring the fact that it's an error
yes which is I think quite important you
know you want it to be as L low effort
as possible for for the developer to
initiate an error because people are
lazy and if it's if there's a lot of
ceremony involved in doing that people
will try to do it as little as possible
um yeah of course but I mean I think
that okay so what you're saying is that
it's a a guaranteed failing confirm is
one approach
yeah because what's what's happening
here is where whereas confirm says let
me check this and if it fails blow up
okay what this is is a blow up you know
definitively blow up yeah which just
raay just completely utterly does not
get that idea
across now I mean one question is could
we have inclose catch whatever it is
that is the semantics of enclose right
for catching the thing let let's say you
say um you know fail
now whatever it is that's the
thing I mean confirm
blows up if it sees a failure right so
sort of the natural thing to do would be
to say essentially fail
now yeah your version of fail but I
think it might be clearer to just say
fail
now yeah and then the question is could
that now be caught just like you have
confirm says if it if it is a failure
then fail but fail now is just a
definitive
failure I thought Christopher and I like
a couple of years ago we should arrange
this meeting at a time when Christopher
can come um the uh uh had a had a
version of this and and when we were
talking about the confirm
design we we should ask about that but
okay let's assume this is called fail
now for
now and that that does what Ray does
basically now the question is do we need
handle or can enclose be the thing that
catches a fail
now yeah so if you look at the Syntax
for enclose it
is um I mean it's one argument form
is not an operator um which is one of
the things that we you you'll mention
you liked about handle in the last
meeting is that it's an operator you can
see an example on the left there The
Notebook on the far left of your screen
the ability to have you know an operator
form where the rules the pattern that's
being matched is something you can
prefix before your function definition
is very very useful for readability
um enclos doesn't really have that
property because it's one argument form
has already defined it's possible that
its two argument form you know it's
currently its two argument form is a
function that gets applied to object
generated presumably we could Define
that so that if that second argument is
a pattern you know a rule or a list of
rules
um then but this is still not the
operator form by the way I don't know
why there's a space the beginning of
that I mean just a
bug oh my God don't you can't be serious
that this stupid raft is broken again in
this prototype build it better not be
the
case we've been through that like 18
times and making sure this actually
comes up see that space that's a bug auy
please make sure that
I don't understand why this raft went
away at that
time it shouldn't go away when I just
Mouse down
there God it shouldn't go away when I
Mouse into that that region there okay I
mean I don't know how many times I have
to you know Define this can we please
take that to the user assistance group
tell them to fix that yep we'll do do
you understand the issue do you
understand the isue
if I'm over that thing there it stays
but if I go there which is what I would
where I would go to start typing the
arguments of the function which is
precisely when I need the raft up it
goes away yep I understand okay all
right
so look the thing
that
no no that's not
um but what is it really it's
really handle is the totally the wrong
name for this because it's
it's okay what does it exactly do now so
if that f is a pattern or a set of rules
and a fail now within exper is is thrown
um and the thing that's thrown matches
that pattern then it will be caught and
that will be the evaluation result of
that whole subv value
form
okay well we got to have a name that
says that which is not handle
yeah okay
so I mean it's close closer to something
like catch
failure yeah actually one of the things
I have in my notes is is this idea of um
a name like try catch which at the very
I mean it's it that name has other
problems but it at least it has catch in
it and it's consistent with what this
form is most similar to in other systems
which is literal you know there's a
block that you're trying and if
something goes wrong rules you're using
to I don't particularly like that name
yeah okay so
this operator form we have all these
applied family like you know reverse
it's a little different isn't it reverse
supplied
fxy this is a little different because
this is
not this is a decorator of
exper that catch a problem inside
expert
yeah I think the thing that's very
unusual about this is that it's a subv
value thing that holds the sub value
arguments I don't know that there's a
lot like that in the system at the
moment I mean I think there can't be
because it's kind of a hack how it works
it returns a function with hold first
attribute
it's a little weird because okay let me
let me try and say it some more this
is okay let's just understand we got
these things
okay we've got this notion of an error
type let's try and try and boil
down okay we've got fail
now which should be catchable by an En
close I
think but then we've got this
alternative
form which is like a confirm is it
not uh no it's not Stephen it's not
because confirm actually tests and then
it blows up while this has a o opposite
nature it actually catches and returns
it doesn't propagate through just
returns Returns what if it if a fail
object so it stops the it stops bubbling
of this failer object up the
stack what do you mean it stops it it
generates a failure object if expert I
don't understand if expert throws a fail
right if expert throws a failure failure
monitor stops that failure it catches it
and returns it Returns what it Returns
the it Returns the failure okay what
does en Clos do relative to
that and clo does a similar thing I
think spoken caus some confus sorry
that's no good we're not going to have
two functions with completely different
naming conventions that do more or less
the same thing I
meaning yeah I don't disagree the name
had to be different for us
to explore the behavior though that's
why we're having a discussion about
naming
okay but I mean so explain to me what's
different between the enclose of
exper okay which if it's a failure
object if xer is a failure
object then in close catches that
failure which has been bubbling up right
from a confirm it bubbled through a
throw it was caught by the
enclose which is extremely similar to
the behavior of fail now bubbling up and
it's caught by the the only difference
is fail now which I'm pretty sure we had
a name for when we're designing confirm
and
close is is the is is the imperative
form of confirm or something is the is
the just fail form of confirm okay which
can be dressed in different ways but
that's basically what it is okay so then
um
okay so that would naturally be caught
that is producing a failure object which
is dressed in some complicated way but
that would be naturally caught by an
enclose
but generically the one argument
inclose well the one argument in close
has this Lexis but maybe that I don't
know
whether does one argument enclose only
catch things
lexically or could one argument close if
it does not find a confirm that matches
it that it can go to a
dynamic you know tag
handling I think it would be a bad
idea I mean it's a question whater to
discuss this okay
yeah meeting when he couldn't come okay
anyway go on yeah well it's it's I mean
there's there's a question of I is it
technically possible for enclosed to do
that probably and that might be worth
doing but then there's also does it does
it is it in violation of people's
expectations existing users of confirm
and close like is it too weird that this
thing is trying to do it has already
pretty subtle lexical Behavior you know
confirm and close are there's not a lot
of like them in the system so their
their behavior their existing behavior
is already very subtle if there this
additional subtlety that enclos also has
non so long as it does the right thing
for people I think subtlety can be
overlooked
yeah you know because nobody would
notice it it's just it does the right
thing I mean there plenty of situations
in the system with all kinds of
complicated scoping where nobody ever
noticed you know it just does the right
thing
yeah so I think I mean it'd be worth I
mean if we think of a slightly larger
example right I mean suppose in close I
mean it could be as simple as exper is a
call to a function Foo right and Fu
inside of it has a fail now yeah if en
close I mean one of the other odd things
about this is that we're very
intentionally designing the system for
it to be relatively easy for you to
provide the pattern that says what you
do and don't want to catch I think it
would work I mean let me propose
something so suppose enclose works non-
lexically and it's single argument form
and we we we'll we'll worry about the
operator form thing later but you know
enclose of exper will
catch fail Nows as well as confirms um
and fail Nows from
anywhere the second question is how do
we specify that the patterns we want to
catch right now in close yeah sorry go
ahead no no well I'm just I'm just
describing so so in close right now I
think it would be helpful if you could
do question mark and close just so this
is on the screen
um yeah or have the do
um so en closes second usage message
it's two argument form right now is a
it's any expression it's you know
something that's going to get applied
to the caught failure um the lexically
caught
failure it would probably be possible
for us without breaking back I know I
know I know to have to have some hack
where that can be a pass I don't think
that's useful I think we should have
another function that is called
something like enclosed pattern which is
a condition
enclose
yeah okay well if we're okay with having
a different symbol just along with more
consist name enclose match or something
enclose
um because then this if we gave this the
right
name then this could potentially have an
operative form which would be exactly
your current handle yeah so I will I
will have a non-operator form it could
if you know let's say we have enclosed
pattern and um it's not the right name
uh yeah I mean and you want a pattern
here it's not a test it's a pattern
right it's a pattern pattern or rules
yeah yeah let's say something like en
Clos
matching
uh actually a good
name I don't I don't think it's quite
right but it's closer okay so
then now this takes a I mean in its full
form it could take could be like this
and then have an operator
form that's enclosed matching pattern
expert
yeah
exactly now I I do want to say the only
thing I mean what I don't like about
this name is that if this is
explicitly I mean it may also have the
lexical behavior of enclos but it's
we're introducing this explicitly for
much expanded non-lexical usage the word
enclose to me doesn't say it doesn't in
evoke any feelings of this is about
failures this is about error handling
Etc it's meant to evoke the lexical
behavior of confirm and clo that's I
think why the name clo was chosen so no
it was it was enclosed the reason the
name enclosed was was chosen was because
it all kinds of muddiness happen inside
the enclosure but the goats never get
out where the goats in this case of
failure
objects right yeah that was the idea the
idea was outside of the of the enclos
it's all clean you don't have to worry
about propagating failures through the
enclose the enclos is going to enclose
it so I don't think this is what's that
yeah I just wanted to say that in that
sense since we uh catch only selective
things with the where the tags match in
certain way then certain things will
propagate through enclosed matching or
whatever we name it which will not match
the tanks so in that if your pattern is
goat but not human humans can escape the
enclosure but not the goats indeed
that's the idea it's like one of those
cow one of those things for cows on the
you know the grills on the road type
thing um yeah it was true for the older
enclos as well of course if you use the
tanks so it's not new here right I mean
the enclosure is
imperfect
um
now the question would
be could confirm itself end up sending
through these stack Trace type things
and so on I don't see why it
shouldn't well it's a question of the
syntax it supports I mean right
now like let's say we were to use the
exact same syntax I mean that would not
work directly
because confirm with a first argument of
let's say a string that has existing
meaning it's like it should just return
the string because it's not a failure
right exactly but but I mean I I think
that when okay so I'm claiming okay
let's imagine that we have a thing
called failure
structure okay which is your dressed
complicated failure thing okay and that
confirm is extended so it it coughs up
failure structures just like it coughs
up um failures if you get what I'm
saying but Stephen let me ask then how
would we distinguish between uh confirms
which are lexical uh and confirms that
propagate these fail structures with
tags uh which are non-lexical should we
just base that on presence of the tags
in this failer in this failer that we
form well I was thinking I mean right
now confirm has a lexical
form yeah but in clear I mean confirms
lexical form is not up to confirm it's a
property of enclose enclose you know
does a rule replace on the body of the
experts en closing to replace lexically
placed confirms with like unique symbols
that are how it actually accomplishes
that so it's I think we should not think
of this as a property of the enclose you
know enclose it depends on what's
outside of it so we don't have to change
per se what in confirm does to decide
whether it's going to be lexical or not
we can just say any confirm that hasn't
been replaced with one of these special
confirms knows that it's not inside of
an enclose and therefore is
nonlexical so it's we don't need special
syntax to distinguish it a non-lexical
versus lexical confirm the issue is okay
let's take a fail now inside and
enclose
is there a sense in
which the fail now should be paired with
its enclosing and
close I think yes I think it's the same
deal as with confirm I think it's
convenient to have this local lexical
form as well as this if there
isn't okay if there is a confirm without
a
tag it's going to be Lex I because what
else could it do what else is going to
do it's going to otherwise it's going to
just I don't know what it does it's like
throw then you might as well use
throw well but the whole the whole point
of what we're trying to achieve here is
a much more I mean not the whole point
but a big part of what we're trying to
achieve here is the convenience of a you
know a very short Syntax for raising you
know for throwing failures it's not
merely that yeah I understand I
understand but but I'm I'm saying you're
saying a tag list
you have a tagless raise but you don't
have a tagless raise you insist on
having a tag in your
raise well that's just so it doesn't it
doesn't conflict with people who are
using tagless throw and catch and other
places for control flow but wait a
minute do you want a tagless raise or
not we definitely don't want it okay
fine then then you have then your
minimal syntax involves some kind of tag
you've managed to make the tag simpler
by using a a uh uh create what are you
calling it create error type thing right
that's your way of defining of aliasing
sort of assigning a name to an aror type
so that you don't have to write out a
whole big thing yeah but it does a
little bit more than that because now
the tags get embedded into the object
that we're propagating they're not
external to it right I me the point is
that yeah it's a property of the thing
that's thrown how it's tagged not okay
that's fine but but my point that I'm
making is there's no conflict here I
mean confirm with two arguments you're
going to have to have two arguments for
this thing fail
now well actually I don't understand
fail now needs only one argument it
doesn't need an expert it just needs the
failure it just needs the tag doesn't it
yes okay so that's fine so then confirm
if it has a tag it can have the same
kind of tag that fail now has so other
words if you've declared a tag let's say
you use
confirm with
um of xer with what I could call a
declared
tag okay because I don't think the tags
management right now is that wonderful
so having some notion of a declared tag
and this is also if it is used in this
form it's either a declared
tag or it's a fail
now with something which is essentially
a failure
structure
right with all that stuff explicitly
pulled in am I
right yeah I just what is expert in this
in
this and what
Duality well yeah I if if if if we're
trying to say that fail now is I think
what you're trying to say but correct me
if I'm wrong is that there's a fail now
is equivalent to some more elaborate
form of invoking confirm no I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that okay I'm
confused what you're saying okay
confirm tests exper okay so this might
be equ fail now might be equivalent to
if failure
Q
exper fail
now actually it's confirmed that's going
to be equivalent to this yeah that's
equivalent to
confirm of exper comma whatever fail now
of tag
yes that's what I'm saying
right and that's pretty nice in my
opinion yeah I agree and actually one of
the syntaxes that I I I you could
imagine this doing right and I'm not
sure we'd want to overload this Behavior
but you could think of this as like yeah
it's it's it's just a convenient way to
say this expert and this is the same
thing goes for confirm quiet and confirm
match too right where you might want to
say if you don't provide a custom tag
then it's one kind of confirm it's like
this is a you know it's a default
confirm with the default tag which is
the existing behavior of confirm if you
provide a custom tag and possibly also
you know a SE like a format string is a
third argument and then a sequence of
arguments after that it's just a
convenient way of saying if this is
wrong you know the confirm fails then
raise a failure with this custom tag and
custom error message um yeah very use
right to me yeah yeah yeah right and and
including the other things like confirm
quiet and so on which we don't want to
have to have a raise if quiet type thing
and and you know the whole point is we
don't want to have to have an if blah
blah blah raise yeah sometimes you do
want that that's why we want fail now
exactly
yeah yeah okay
so then the question here
is in close in its usual form can take a
tag right no it doesn't it takes takes a
form I see it takes a tag right as a
last it takes a tag as a third argument
yeah it takes a tag but not very
pleasantly so the more common case would
be that you say enclose
matching also in the in close matching
we could have several Alternatives shown
as rules so that it can handle different
exceptions at the same time producing
different out
definitely and that's a powerful
capability okay yeah all right but what
what is the right name for this the
right name for this
is if it doesn't match
pattern then it just blows right
through right it's a charging giraffe
and it just goes right through the
enclosure is that correct yep
yeah it's not
enclosed
yeah oh formally enclos is also this way
if it if it's used with the tag and I
understand the tag is not third argument
yes
yeah
um
yeah I mean this is this is a good
mechanism I I not it's close enclos
matching is close I'm not sure it's you
know I keep on thinking of enclose if
but it isn't right because it's not
that's a
pattern see what I'm
saying
yeah I mean is it
like I mean enclose when a it's kind of
a condition but that's not right either
no it's not
right I mean and and the other thing
which we also can't use as enclos
for enclos
for
yeah
um okay we we're close but we're not
quite there but I think this this
mechanism I think this is the right
mechanism and close matching for this
case this is a good second I mean I I
think this is the right argument order
for
this
um
now I think we
want
either register failure tag or set
failure tag depending on the
syntax
yeah so what is for that what is the
create error type syntax it's current
syntax is the first argument always is
always a symbol the second argument is
always a list of symbols but I think
that this is like I mean I don't feel
comfortable with the syntax at least in
sense of like knowing that it's the
final syntax because there's a number of
things that we think we want to do but
haven't done yet for example the ability
to associate some kind of validation
function with a tag so you can say you
know make sure that every tag you every
failure raised with that tag has a
particular property like let's say that
every you know file IO error has a file
property and its failures um and we
don't have a Syntax for that so we've
got something like this but then failure
structure would be the thing
that
um I I don't like structure because it
sounds like it's too much like data
structure which is kind of an inert
thing it's an object it's not a it's not
a
verb um I mean maybe construct
failure right because we basically want
some special
Constructor yeah but we
want
uh how about current
failure because in a sense well that
isn't quite right but the idea there is
that it is it is packaging up something
about the current state
yeah I mean I think we're imagining use
use stack presumably I don't failure
stack is not a good name either it's too
specific
um stack failure that's not the right
either something I mean maybe maybe I
begin failure but that's not right um no
I mean it's right in the sense that if
you know it's something it's going to be
thrown it's like I want to know where
this started you know I I know I'm just
I'm trying to I'm trying to explore just
capturing the current
state maybe failure with
State uh yeah but but but that suggests
that it is um we want it to know that
it's making a failure I I think having a
prefix word to failure is okay um
I'm me just throwing out some ideas but
make failure emit failure textual
failure contextual failure yeah that's
not terrible close it's not quite it's
not quite right but it's
close it's close because we really want
to capture that we are assembling the
context to that failure of the error
exactly yeah but it also sounds like
something that's parallel to failure it
cre creates a failure it evaluates
failure it's not contextualized
failure we really want to make it
long yeah but I mean unfortunately we
our notion of context is a different
thing yeah
um this is close the concept is
contextualized
failure where
you sorry go ahead well if it just needs
to be a verb I mean contextualize
failure
why is it a
verb because it's it's and I I want it
because I think we want to get across
the fact that it's doing something it's
capturing a stack Trace it's you know I
don't know looking up it's also a
failure that I mean what are its
arguments a tag an association a string
format parameters and then possibly
options if you want to like at at the
call site explicitly disable you give a
failure you're also giving a tag and
other things right so this is a failure
that has been
contextualized yes
exactly I don't think you by saying
contextualize I don't think you're
saying that the context is something you
have to feed
in
MH yeah contextual contextualized
already kind of implies that certain
work has been done to create it
yeah well okay these aren't quite right
but we're getting there okay I think
we've got contextualized failure we've
got enclosed matching and we've got fail
now
um and then we've got some kind of set
failure
tag yeah or or even perhaps Define
tag yeah Define is probably better yeah
I think so
too because set implies that some
something already existed while Define
implies that we are making it up yep and
I mean I think we've got a bunch of
things in the compiler space that uh
Define
whatever yeah I me I think one advantage
of register is that it it naturally
suggests the notion it begs the question
of unregistered failure tags which I
think we probably want to support like
that this this Machinery works even for
tags that haven't been registered but
you can opt into additional Behavior by
registering well but the fact that you
define a failure tag means just like you
can use the symbol X without giving it
value yeah all right we should wrap we
got to go to another live stream meeting
here
um I think we make making good progress
let's pick this up up again before we've
all forgotten how this works let's try
to make sure Christopher can join the
next time and let's uh show him what
we've got so far so maybe somebody can
summarize for
him sure uh can somebody I mean Stephen
or somebody else here who knows figure
out how to send me this notebook that
Stephen's been taking notes into I
assume auy can yeah I can send it to you
okay thank you
auy okay see y' all soon thank youbody
bye
by and